the web 2.0 movement and this whole tech
scene right now and the people with
personal brand like Scoble and iJustine
and cal canis and kevin rose are exactly
who LL Cool J and Run DMC and the
Beastie Boys were in 1985 and don't get
it twisted I'm dead serious
hip-hop 85 is equal to tech web 2.0 2008
let me break it down for you it's very
simple as this there's no doubt in my
mind that the people that have personal
brand in this movement right now over
the next decade will have enormous
opportunity for monetizing
I hate every tech thing when people
present how you gonna monetize it of
course that's what everybody thinks
about but going back to the legacy is
greater than currency if you're talking
about what you believe in and you're
building your personal brand in this
space right now I think you were
absolutely hitting some vocal and a very
important vocal critical point
sorry that's other brain work sometimes
critical points in this huge
opportunistic era that is the gold rush
of personal brand here's how I see it
the kids that are 12 13 14 and 15 right
now if you really break them down if you
really check them out I know I'm gonna
go to jail eventually but if you really
study them and see what they're into
they are all about using technology
social networking I am in texting I mean
you go hang out with 12 year olds this
is all they're doing all day
they're like no no no no no I mean
they're all about it that is the same
thing you saw in the ghettos and in the
urban areas of the u.s. in 85 86 87 they
were not listening to white lion or
Billy Idol or the Rolling Stones or
whatever else Madonna Prince Michael
Jackson that point they were listening
to the hip hop rap movement and the
people that emerged from that era have
absolutely hit homeruns if you don't
think jay-z or P Diddy or even Rev Run
with you know his show on MTV or Russell
Simmons who really capitalized on a
movement and saw and had patience and
this is where I'm getting to at the crux
in it I've got a fancy title I really
believe it but here's the key patience
to many people right now are scared and
want to say it's over everything's
happened or more importantly have not
realized that this is just the beginning
my friends this is the national
in an 18-inning baseball game that's
where we're at right now in the tech
branding part of things in next seven to
15 years as these twelve year olds
become pretty much part of the community
and part of the world and the decision
makers in this world the advertising
buyers the the people that spend the
dough they're gonna be used to and it's
going to be in their DNA to understand
this just like the executives who now
sign deals with hip-hop artists all the
biggest brands in the world now want to
associate themselves with the little
John's or the Lil Wayne's or the Kanye
West's of the world go back 15 20 years
ago and that was not the case and the
thing is you don't want to hear that it
takes a lot of work and a lot of
patience but guess what that is the end
game my friends what we are sitting on
right now is a golden era to build our
brand because the barrier of entry is
zero
we don't need record labels to make us
famous we can do it ourselves by putting
out a video in two seconds or writing a
smart blog post and then we got to sit
on some patience and let society move
into us because I'm telling you right
now that is exactly what is happening
right now every 12 13 14 year old is
absolutely positively ready to embrace
Twitter and Flickr and quick and I need
technology whatsoever because it's in
their blood it's in their DNA it's the
same reason we have 35 year old gamers
now playing Nintendo Wii because they
grew up in it but in 1985 when Nintendo
came out you didn't have 35 year old
gamers pay attention to trends realize
what we're sitting on and understand
that if you keep doing it every day and
you survive and you can pay the bills
and you love your family if you're
building brand equity in this space
people are gonna come running to you and
there's gonna be enormous opportunity
but it's gonna take 5-10 years that's
why you got to do what you love but I'm
telling you right now hip-hop 85 looks
exactly like tech bubble 2008